[Music]
hello in a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga where we're looking at the
fallout from the nuclear summit in
Singapore between US President Donald
Trump and North Korean leader Kim
jong-un now at the meeting there were
historic handshakes followed by the
signing of what was described as a
comprehensive document in which Trump
and Kim promised to work towards the
complete denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula the question is though will
these two volatile leaders keep their
promises and is this agreement only
going to upgrade the international
standing of a murderous dictator so our
question here on quadriga this week is
Trump and Kim a big deal and to answer
that question I'm joined here in the
studio by Sasha Hutt an expert on
disarmament with ICANN Germany the Nobel
prize-winning Organization for the
abolition of nuclear weapons he says
Trump and Kim's deal doesn't go far
enough to succeed the denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula has to be
embedded in international law and other
actors need to be involved also with us
is Matthew College Nick chief Europe
correspondent for Politico and Matthew
argues that it may be hard for many to
accept but Trump was right
just getting the North Koreans to the
table to seriously talk peace is an
impressive outcome and a very warm
welcome to today I am from the Korea
communication Research Center here in
Berlin who believes that properly
knowing and understanding North Korea is
the key to peace well thank you all
three of you for being here with me
today on quadri I'd like to begin with
you DYI and South Korean president moon
jae-in has been quoted as saying that
the Trump Kim summit opens the way to a
new era of peace and cooperation on the
Korean Peninsula do you agree I totally
agree it's a very historical moment yeah
with the South and North Korean summit
in April and also the following summit
which happened few days ago I think it's
very historical that North Korea came to
the neck
shishun table on the same level with us
and also when we look at the articles of
the agreement the article number one was
not the nuclearization which is very
unfair for north what which could be
unfair for North Korea however they
first said that the new relationship
between US and North Korea would be the
priority for them and also the peace
regime should be protected and also us
have acknowledged to protect the regime
of North Korea and to give security
protections for North Korea which is a
big success which I believe in this
summit and also they have the article of
denuclearization which has some
controversies however for this step is
the first step of us and North Korea
right now and for the first step I think
it was enough and it's totally
successful so should I assume given
everything that you're saying that there
is a mood of euphoria in South Korea at
this point in time yes we find more hope
and I assume and I also personally
experienced that many Koreans had fear
in their heart fear of war and this was
hided for them inside of them for many
years and for their entire lives
because when they face the fear that is
inside their heart the fear of war from
outside powers then they cannot survive
for their whole life because it's they
know how the fascinating the situation
will be however now they overcame
somewhat in a way of their fears they're
trying to step further and they are
making festivals out of they are
feasting this summit and also they are
they found some hope in the Korean
Peninsula that peace can actually be
made in this Korean Peninsula so very
positive to Matthew College Nagar Donald
Trump the dealmaker has scored a great
victory in Singapore well it might be
too early to claim great victory but I
think just the fact as I said that you
know he got the North Koreans to the
table and that they're discussing
substantive issues or will be in
coming weeks is is something that one
one shouldn't downplay at this point I
think there's always a lot of skepticism
in here these arguments well he's
putting him on a pedestal or he's
allowing him to have this sort of
perception that he's the world leader
that he's legitimizing him at the same
time though I feel this is exactly what
we've done with with Putin for years and
here we have a leader who is in many
people's you responsible for using
chemical weapons in Syria who has
annexed Crimea as we know who is
fighting a war in Ukraine and in Europe
nobody has a problem with talking to
well I don't think that they're
necessarily two wrongs make a right I
think that if you argue as many people
do that dialogue is important in
diplomacy that you're not going to get
anywhere if you don't speak to the other
side then I don't see how you can be
against a meeting like this because you
also have to acknowledge that the North
Koreans have these nuclear weapons now
and we can't change that it's too late
you know the the period where we can
ignore them as previous American
administrations did essentially thinking
that well we're going to just pressure
them with sanctions and at some time at
some point they're gonna come to the
table well that that strategy didn't
work and now we're at a stage I think
where they just they're not just working
on nuclear weapons they don't just have
one nuclear weapon they apparently have
an entire arsenal and I think what Trump
has done is basically to acknowledge
this reality and say we can't pretend
that this isn't the case anymore we have
to deal with them and if that means
legitimizing him then then so be it I
mean what is really the consequence of
that what is the negative consequence in
the long term of legitimizing this
regime that my eyes are getting more and
more critical no I agree that it is a
historic meeting I also agree that it's
a great progress and it's an absolutely
important to keep in touch until there's
a safer place of dialogue in a certain
way yes because
who does not threat who does not shoot
but talk is certainly I'm giving more
security to the word what I'm worrying
about is how lasting how long this
Agreement or this declaration will last
when this testosterone cloud of
Singapore is left and also I would like
to raise the question who is actually
behind this cloud or are there other
actors who have also contributed to this
example to this meeting namely the South
Korean Prime Minister moon jae-in and
also China and certain where we know
that Kim jong-un has been twice to China
before this meeting took place so we
should not believe or trust too much in
this two men show that Donald Trump and
Kim Jung hoon were presenting that bus
but also consider all the relevant
actors that play the main role in the
Korean War and acknowledge that they
from now on also have to be integrated
in any process of disarmament and peace
in the region namely China and South
Korea it cannot be just an issue between
the u.s. and North Korea and second we
have to embed this declaration which is
non-binding without any like
verification system or town but a time
bound plan we have to embed this in
international public law so that we have
a structure which makes this agreement
which gives this agreement a perspective
and the treaty we are proposing is the
one of the prohibition of the nuclear
weapons I mean I agree that China is
involved should be involved I don't
think that you can have lasting peace in
in Korea obviously without South Korea
but South Korea's the really the one
who's been been pushing this and if you
look at what what you know president
moon said when it looked like the the
the meeting wasn't going to happen and
and the South Korean reaction I mean
they were absolutely
essential to this process in China I
mean given that China is really the the
country that enabled North Korea to have
these weapons in the first place by
standing by and allowing this nuclear
program to progress it's clear that this
is all of one piece but I think this is
exactly what you want you don't just
want the United States and and the North
Koreans to be sitting down at the table
and you know Russia is going to have to
be involved in this process at some
point too but I I do think that in the
end if it does progress and in my view
this was just a first step
it was more of an icebreaker than
anything it would have been unrealistic
to think that Trump would come out of
that meeting with a sort of full-blown
treaty that was you know ready to be
signed whereby the North Koreans would
be foregoing nuclear weapons forever
but at least you know he has created an
atmosphere it appears where these
negotiations can't continue we've been
here before in the past but again I
don't see any reason why we shouldn't
give him the benefit of the doubt and I
think that if it had been a different
president if it weren't Trump you know
many of the the criticisms that you're
hearing now would not be you know would
not be out there mm-hmm let's just
remind ourselves of where we have come
from in the last couple of months it all
began of course with the conventional
slanging match that turned into a
nuclear slanging match here some images
the run-up to the summit was horribly
entertaining Kim was quick to shoot back
I will surely and definitely tame the
mentally deranged us dotard with fire
Trump was not to be trumped they will be
met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen the question of central
concern who has the bigger and more
powerful nuclear button the two seem to
get along and they know how to put on a
show their war games over now
who should take the biggest credit for
the for the breakthrough that we have
seen Donald Trump or somebody else well
I think this is a very guided question
however to be honest I would like to
give the biggest credit to president
moon jaein who is the current president
of South Korea mm-hm because firstly he
has changed the game
he led Korea the two Koreas to be in the
center of the negotiation table so now
it's not about other states talking
about the situation in Korean Peninsula
but moons president moon jae-in
has lead it the negotiations in most
other countries and secondly I believe
that president moon jae-in has a big
credit to continue the summit the u.s.
and North Korea summit was about to be
collapsed however he called North Korea
Kim jong-un right away and he talked
with kim jongwan and he negotiated with
him and he lead it North Korea and us to
finally meet together so whether or not
this will last long or it will just be a
show as some people have argued I think
that the fact that u.s. and North Korea
has met on the negotiation table has a
big meaning and the historical
perspective and for this I get I believe
that President Jane made a big fool mmm
so Sasha with the situation has moved
forward but there everybody is say there
are problems with the timetabling and
especially with the details of this
agreement what's missing um it is
missing a verification is this missing
actually concrete assignments steps and
the plan for this almond but it is clear
for this meeting it was not nobody
expected really that they could within
the time they had have such a result
however we need now yeah legal structure
in which we integrate this peace process
in this legal structure has to consider
both sides not only North the North
Korean side when we are talking about
the denuclearization of the Korean
Peninsula
we've only no obligations declaration by
North Korea none of the yes but there is
the US nuclear umbrella protecting South
Korea which has a geopolitical impact on
the whole region so we also have to
address this issue that means we need a
legal framework that integrates both
sides not only the nuclear weapons state
but also the state under the umbrella
and the only legal system that I know
which takes this into account is
currently this new treaty on the
provisional nuclear weapons which also
outlaws the threat of nuclear weapons
and nuclear sharing so this could be a
framework or structure in which we could
move for it take to put that framework
in place I like since essentially I
believe that you have to take a long
time in to account technically is
precisely what the world and what the
impatient Donald Trump does not want he
wants this to happen very quickly indeed
is it he is it in any way possible for
denuclearization to happen I don't know
in a framework of a year let's say
technically yes it is very easily
possibility to dismantle the nuclear
weapons is if there is political will
but you said the world once and then you
knew correct that Donald Trump once I
think this is an important difference
because I think the priority of South
Korea of course they are threatened by
the nuclear weapons but they want to
move forward with a reconciliation and
peace process and they are okay with a
step-by-step approach China is as well
and I think that we need time for such
an assignment process we just need a
security and sound
lasting framework but it was interesting
at the press conference Donald Trump you
know when he was asked about the the
timeframe a timeline for any or all of
this he said he would like to you to
happen as fast as it can be done
mechanically and physically what was
very interesting you're saying it could
actually happen within a year
yeah I mean it could even happen in a
few months if you withdraw if you remove
the warheads and bring them to the earth
to dismantle them but this is it is not
a technical question it is a political
question and as long as nuclear weapons
remain the geopolitical center of the
world order and it remains so attractive
for countries to attain to first protect
themselves but also to have this
prestige to talk to the most powerful
man of the world as we just saw it as
long as we don't solve this geopolitical
problem of status of nuclear weapons
we will not see North Korea getting rid
of its nuclear weapons very quickly
because that's the very function of
nuclear weapons for akin hmm when we
talk about Kim what can you tell us
about Kim to help us to understand the
man get a little bit closer to the man
well I don't personally know however
what I can say is I feel personally that
he was quite genuine and I think he was
consistent with what he really wants
North Korea wants their regime to be
acknowledged and protected that's the
number-one priority for them they we
have to really think about why they are
trying to possess and develop nuclear
weapons is it because they want to make
a war against the other countries it's
obvious that they can't really win the
war so it's just their own button or a
leverage for them to make the status quo
in North Korea to be stabilized so if we
acknowledge North Korea at the same
level level then North Korea will step
forward the denuclearization process and
in this sense I found that Kim jong-un
was quite genuine in his way during the
two summits the last two summits and
also he is what I find for me him is
that he is eager for the poor peace in
the Korean Peninsula
he wants to denuclearize nuclear weapons
if his regime is protected and if his if
North Korean security can be protected
so in this sense I find him very
positive toward the peace regime in the
Korean Peninsula and also in the global
society
also he is quite eager to this
denuclearized his the nuclear weapons in
North Korea however what I was I made a
I have a I found the problem in many
media and also many of the public
opinions they only put conditions for
denuclearization they only focus on the
nuclearization of North Korea why don't
they put any conditions for us or the
other countries not to intervene into
the regime or not to propagate them
anymore I think this kind of very
filtered and prejudiced viewpoints
should actually change in order for this
summit or in order for this agreement to
last long if North Korea is not
acknowledged by the global society or if
there are so many suspicions behind Kim
jong-un's purpose which he never said
about then this agreement will not last
long
of course and of course the peace regime
cannot last long okay interesting
insights despite all that the the fact
remains chairman Kim of North Korea is
without doubt an autocrat a despot and
the big question surrounding his future
is will he be able to survive the
process of transformation that now at
least looks possible on the Korean
Peninsula the troops the North Korean
dictator commands are not toy soldiers
the region is one of the world's most
heavily militarized and North Korea
claims to have nuclear weapons Kim
jong-un is unpredictable and it's not
clear how firm his grip on power really
is
starting in 2010 he was groomed as
successor to his father Kim jong-il the
next object of adoration in the
personality cults surrounding the Kim
dynasty upon assuming power Kim jong-un
was quick to do away with perceived
threats such as his uncle Jang
song-thaek who was arrested subjected to
a show trial and executed he had been
number two in the leadership North Korea
presents itself as a model communist
state cautiously opening up to the
outside world behind the scenes however
famine torture labor camps according to
people who managed to flee what does Kim
really want good question Mathew what
does Kim really want well I tend to
think that he wants a deal and I think
it is important to remember that this is
an autocratic regime some would say it's
a rogue regime and if you look at what
they've done in the past you know an
counterfeiting US currency which was a
huge operation that they undertook or
that the cyber warfare that they've
engaged in it's clear that this this
nuclear push that they've undertaken
over the past couple of decades is aimed
at at some point getting something back
and I I think that although a lot of
people laugh at Trump and this
deal-making sort of aura that he tries
to project that he might have found the
one country where this could actually
work and I I think you you felt that a
little bit at this summit I mean if you
remember you know Kim came in on a on a
Chinese airliner I think it shows that
this is not a country that is you know
particularly wealthy in in reality that
has the kind of resources that it would
like to have he made a big deal about
seeing Trump's limousine and and and and
this kind of thing so I do think it is
the the kind of leader where Trump's
approach to diplomacy as it were could
actually work if Kim wants a deal does
he want to deal where he keeps the
nuclear weapons or where he loses the
nuclear weapons well he won't get a deal
if he doesn't lose the nuclear weapons
of course I think he would prefer to
keep the nuclear weapons that's not
gonna happen the US won't do it how can
he survive in that scenario he's gonna
be washed away by history well I think
if he
you know agrees to open up North Korea
and get some sort of economic benefits
in return for giving up the nuclear
weapons which is exactly what Trump has
offered him then he will have something
that he can you know sell to the rest of
the regime and and you know it's
important to remember there is this
whole class of leaders in in North Korea
behind and I thought it was interesting
in the run-up to the summit that he
fired a couple of the top generals which
you know many thought is indication that
not not everybody is really on board
with this plan but you know clearly he's
the man in control he and his sister and
they're there they're pushing this
through and I don't think that they
would have embarked on this course
and gone this far if they they weren't
really willing to give something up
Sasha how similar is the situation in
Korea today to the situation in Germany
back in the 1980s the late 1980s know
it's a tough question but I'm very
interested in what you have to say I was
very young in Germany we have talked
about that in the mask actually that the
situation is very different in my point
of view so economically speaking
politically speaking we cannot compare
the two systems and also with regard of
nuclear weapons and the role of nuclear
weapons although also the international
alliance structure was completely
different if we compared to Germany to
Korea today however what I would still
like to promote or keep in mind is that
the German example as well as the
Vietnamese example show that there is
hope even for cases that's Mabley
similarity okay cases which seem
desperate and without hope and the
perspective perspective that we have now
that the talks and the dialogue
continues with concrete trust-building
measures for example with the bodies of
the the remnants of the Korean War being
moved repatriated which means talks and
meetings will continue this perspectives
I think it gives truly hope enjoy the
process do the people of North and South
Korea want reunification do they still
want reunification yes they want
reunification because we had a
provincial election yesterday and out of
seventeen provinces 14 provinces have
voted for the Democratic Party which is
the party of the president moon and this
shows how much support are given by the
citizens of Korea for the reunification
process and the peace regime and I
really want to say that we really have
to know North Korea well not know we
have to accept that we don't know North
Korea about we don't know about North
Korea that much because we are only
watching the news that are filtered by
the media and by the by the majorities
so we have to listen carefully of what
really North Korea wants and what they
really want to pursue and this is the
only way that we can step toward peace
and this is what I really want to say I
once I once with a fellow journalist
walked along the Berlin Wall and we were
looking at it and wondering whether it
would disappear in our lifetimes and
each of us said well maybe if we're very
lucky indeed within a year it had gone
how soon do you think we might see
reunion and in South Korea in your in
your lifetime before I pass away I want
to see the reunification process of
course but I think it's very dangerous
if we make it too quick because we have
to have some steps before we make the
real reunification we have to make it
peaceful okay thanks very much all of
you for joining me here today to talk
about the Singapore summit great stuff
if you've enjoyed the show as much as I
have to do come back next week until
11:00 bye-bye and just
[Music]
you